so hello everyone I'm very excited to
talk to you about proximity matching
with random forests today I'll quickly
introduce myself my name is Anna I work
at lendable a little fin tech startup
company and we Rufus and so to say the
link between alternative lenders in East
and sub-saharan Africa and investors in
the US or Europe and we help to a kind
of our alternative lenders our customers
to grow in a reliable and fast way and
we do that by purchasing part of their
portfolio that could be micro loans or
asset-backed loans work like motorbikes
solar panels and stuff like that
and we use our heavily for portfolio
managing and portfolio monitoring as
well as to predict default raids or cash
flows with our risk engine so after we
purchased our portfolio we have a leg up
we maintain our ongoing relationship
with our clients and we have like
monthly meetings where we talk about the
current portfolio performance and things
like that and the big thing that we
heavily use our n is to monitor
performances and so one major thing is
to look at do they still care about our
portfolio that we have purchased versus
the other kind of part of their
portfolio that we have not purchased the
problem what this is like a randomly
chosen graph from from this kind of
monitoring thing and so in this case the
green one is did not purchase portfolio
and the yellow one is to purchase
portfolio and if if that would be
repayment rates we would be a little bit
concerned this what kind of the normal
portfolio certain say is doing kind of
originally fine and the other one kind
of drops I'm sorry the other way round
nevertheless the problem with this
comparison is when we look into a deal
into purchasing a portfolio we have a
like a very extensive catalogue of
criteria due to legal or investment
rules and things that I'm not that able
to talk about because I don't know them
all but so when we purchase a portfolio
there there's a lot kind of selection
going on so this this comparison is
Spile spider selection filters and there
are multiple ways to solve orders for
this bias nuts and one of them is for
example imagine we ran a forest
spoil alike and I will walk you for an
example we have Land Lending Club data
this is online I will but they do like I
a very similar thing it's an online
platform and you can get a personal loan
for yourself or your business and they
connect you with investors and they have
a huge data set online available and I
use that to kind of walk you for an
example so first of all we create our
chosen purchase portfolio by using
variable filters so for example we look
we only want to kind of collect choose
something between certain interest rates
and and amounts and grades and what
what's in there so in this case I know
exactly what those filters are in some
cases I don't know exactly what those
filters are and or at the data is not
available or it's not collected in an
ongoing way so if we compare now our
purchase portfolio portfolio to the rest
of your portfolio we can see significant
differences in characteristics in this
case it's the loan amount right I mean
we felt that on the loan amount so we
kind of expected that but just to kind
of
keep the example going as well as with
the zip code distribution there is like
a huge difference here indicating that a
raw comparison is like unfair to say the
least so if we would look at like
default rates or number of loan sets are
still active or have fully paid we
should know now that it's it's biased
there is election Folgers going on here
that we should think about what to do so
the question is how can we eliminate the
selection filters to put it in another
question the thing that we want to have
at the end of the day is we want us a
similar group right we want to kind of
find all those inheritant filters those
selection filters that lead to kind of
our chosen portfolio and the key word
here is similarity which kind of pops up
more or less obvious solution to use
proximity scores from random forests and
quickly what is random forest a random
forest is among the humble learner it
uses bootstrap samples and random
feature selection and it consists of
multiple decision trees a decision tree
here represented in our is a
classification algorithm it also can do
linear regression and it starts by
looking at all the available feature
variables and kind of tries to split
each variable into two groups such that
it can label the resulting observations
at so in this case we want to kind of
label our chosen and not chosen
portfolio and you may not be surprised
if we use interest rate and loan amount
our former used filters it can split
those those observations up into the
other portfolio and our chosen
here labeled by other and folio and a
tree really is if you want to kind of
visualize dad in a two-dimensional space
that's really easy to do its feature
space partitioning right so first we had
the slit between the land and the low
amount so we had one group this other
and the other one needed a little bit
more work to kind of split it
indistinguishable groups you may notice
that there's there are a few green dots
in the big blue square some so kind of
this splitting in in decision trees
happens either until you have kind of
sufficient number of observations in
your end notes there are other stopping
rules sometimes you want to kind of grow
it fully so to say that you have like
very very clean and resolved like end
leaves we call and this is a discus kind
of those green dots in the blue it is
one major key point from tree to a
forest you put multiple trees together
you have a forest the randomness in in
the forest comes from two different
parts first of all each based on a
bootstrap sample so usually a sample
that is as big as the original data set
but randomly chosen and you can show
that then like around 2/3 of the entire
data set are in each food shop bootstrap
sample if you said replacement to true
so you're kind of drawing and kind of
putting back again and the other part of
the randomness comes from randomly
charged choosing feature selection
feature variables so oh cool so in each
split when you decide whether or not to
kind of what what variable would be best
to kind of distinguish between Group A
and Group B you not have all the
variables
available but only a random subset of
the rebels which kind of brings another
randomness into the whole tree the
reason to do that I forgot to mention
that earlier is that trees very much
suffer from or overfitting and they're
very very sensitive to like really
really small changes of data and kind of
putting all these trees together with
random feature variable selection and
bootstrap samples kind of helps with
that overfitting it's kind of the whole
part of why we use them so awareness so
what does that mean now for our
observations so imagine each tree has
its own booster example each observation
might be in multiple trees not in all of
them and at each kind of select are kind
of crossing we have other features
available to perform the split and so
observation a might end up labeled as
orange in one tree and as apple in the
other and kind of going through multiple
trees how do we combine all those kind
of labels at the end we usually take the
majority road so each tree labels each
observation and the label kind of in the
end of of each observation is then the
majority vote of all trees so what that
means is based on certain features and
certain characteristics observations can
be considered similar or very very
different right if I if I look into into
this room there's a person we probably
all have seen or used ours so we are
very similar in that kind of field other
may have used a lot of - in the past
others may not so there's a like a
difference in there and if we look at a
feature characteristic of have you used
or seen are you would end up in the end
same kind of labeled group if we look at
the characteristic of have a used or
seen - it may look a little bit
different for various kind of examples
in the room
and so kind of dissimilarity measure is
built in into a random forest and leo
breiman who kind of created the random
forest algorithm mentioned that the
proximity scores that I will introduce
quickly are one of the most useful tools
within a random forest and proximity
scores basically count if observation a
an observation be end up in the same and
now it's only in the same end group they
can be considered similar for that
specific tree and this proximity score
is then raised by one each time that
happens and we can normalize that
measure by the number of trace to get
like a normalized between zero and one
measure and this measure of distance has
free main advantages it's a metric free
you can run the random forest in a
supervised way to kind of backward
engineering your selection rules and it
does not suffer from the curse of
dimension so whatever kind of number of
variables you have put them in there
when the forest will be fine to some
extent take a look at the proximity
matrix I have here observations ABCD and
E and the upper one is to normalize one
and and matrix at the bottom is the one
worries actually count how many times
two observation ended up in the same and
note please note the diagonal has always
has to be one or like the number of
trees and so for example observation B
and observation e did not end up in the
same end note ever while observation
let's take D and observation e ended up
in the same and note five times
observation a and observation D ended up
in the same and not 165 times so out of
ABCD and E well actually be C D and E a
can be considered most similar to
observation D if we if we kind of use
that similarity measurement so how does
it work I can now use that measurement
those proximity scores from a random
forest to create my so called control
group right that treatment group here
would be my purchase portfolio my chosen
portfolio and I want you to find all
those observation in the rest of it it
can be considered most similar to have a
fair comparison so this is the code you
can render an enforced supervised or
unsupervised then you have all those
indices that mark whatever is in your
portfolio already and then you take the
proximity matrix and delete all the
columns for the in-group and it says or
ADIZ and select rows only for those such
that you can find for each in group
observation the one from the other
outside group which has the highest
proximity score
and maybe you remember the main reason
that we kind of wanted to do that is
first of all to find another group that
can be considered similar based on the
characteristics that we're looking at as
well as to kind of backward engineer our
selection rules which we may not know
all the time so we had the zip code and
a loan amount and after proximity
matching it's a lot better which was
kind of hot the whole point of it and
when we look at the zip code I split
them to kind of see it a little bit
better we had those huge spikes right
because we actually selected like
various very specific zip codes but the
kind of overall distribution from what's
left of it is like way more similar than
before another thing that I wanted to
mention is why do we even kind of do
that why don't we just use the same
filters and kind of apply it to the tune
of outside group one problem that is
they might not be available anymore and
so we really have to look at what can be
considered most similar so if we look
now at a comparison and like whatever
performance measure we want to use we
know now that the difference are not
based on the selection Folgers anymore
and when we compare that for example to
run a randomly sampled portfolio to kind
of as a control group we can see that
the characteristics a much more similar
number of the proximity matching so what
about blendable what about our original
problem so we had this comparison
reservoir comparison before and we
actually know it's unfair because we
know that our criteria are very very
specific sometimes and also from a
quality perspective which kind of lays
behind it after proximity matching this
looks a much different first of all and
we can now be sure
that the difference in those performance
metrics are not due to selection filters
anymore which was the whole point of it
so now we can have like a very much
better basis to compare different
performance metrics and to kind of
actually talk about for example was the
original empirical distribution from a
future variable and after proof symmetry
matching it looks much better
yeah and that's that's it thank you very
much
[Applause]